das bedürfnis nach unterhaltung bis teil
der menschlichen natur
die neuen technologien die immer mehr
unser leben bestimmen revolutionieren
auch unser freizeitverhalten neue medien
die unsere sinne ansprechen
unsere fantasie beflügeln türen zu
unbekannten universum öffnen und die
grenzen zwischen virtuellem und realem
auflösen
im mittelpunkt die interaktion dank
neuer verfahren und echtzeit technologie
ist in videospielen alles möglich der
einzige grenze ist deine
vorstellungskraft die wa brille
transportiert uns nicht nur in
fantastische welten was zb jungen
menschen mit handicap ermöglicht klavier
zu spielen
nur indem sie die augen bewegen
[Musik]